hello
uh my name is unaltash and today
i will be talking about our latest
developments on
a symbolic solving of partial
differential equations
so thanks for joining us today and
this is the abstract probably you have
seen this already so
first i will start with classical
uh pd problems uh heat wave
and laplace problems and then also i
will talk about our
new development on uh fairly
modern approaches uh like uniform
transform methods
due to focus and his co-workers
and then i i will conclude with
the conclusion completing remarks
so let me start with heat equation
initial value
boundary value problems
i will start with rectangular
coordinates from one dimension to
through three dimension and the first
example that i want to show is the
insulated bar problem
here uh both ends of the bar
are insulated and the length of the bar
is assumed to be
30 so we have a drill
we have neumann conditions on both ends
and since the bar is insulated the the
derivatives are zero
so uh the solution is returned in terms
of an
infinite sum in the background we are
using separation of variables and
eigenvalue eigenfunction expansion so
for practical reasons we set infinity to
be
500 and if you plot the solution
then the plot looks like this over here
so this is this was the insulated bar
problem
the next problem is when we have a heat
source in the system
so this is the heat source
internal heat source in the system
this time we we have dirichlet boundary
conditions and the solution is
again in terms of an infinite sum and if
you plot the solution
then we get a plot looking like this one
here in the solution the first two
terms are due to the inhomogeneous
boundary conditions at x equals zero
and x equals 30 30.
the next problem is when we have a heat
loss
in the system so this is the term
representing the heat loss
uh again we have richland boundary
conditions
and the solution is an infinite sum as
expected
and when we plot the solution
setting infinity to 500 for practical
purposes we get this as
the plot for the same problem if we
neglect the heat loss
and return back to the original problem
so we remove the
heat loss and plot that
as well so the first plot here is
the problem with the heat loss and the
uh
the one next right to it is the one is
the plot of
the problem with no heat loss
okay this time we have a semi infinite
semi infinite road so
suppose we have a very long road
so we can treat it as in semi
infinite and in this case we just have
one boundary condition
at the starting
x value so the the solution is
returned in terms of error function and
if you plot this
one the the solution will look like this
so in this first one we we had a
dirichlet condition
and if we change the condition to be a
neumann condition
then again we get a piece piecewise
error
error function solution and this time
the solution will be looking like this
one here
next suppose we are at the center of the
very long road so in this case we can
assume that
it extends from minus
infinity to plus infinity so this time
we have an infinite rod and
therefore we don't have any boundary
conditions we just have initial
condition uh the solution is returned in
terms of error function again
and when we plot the solution the
solution will be
looking like this here suppose for the
same
problem we have a ho we have a source
generating heat and the source function
is
uh science function
and this time the solution will have
extra pieces due to this source
and when we plot the solution the
solution will
look like this this time
so uh another method that we use is
uh transforming hard equations into
simpler ones
and for instance suppose we have a
diffusion equation
with this term here so we want to get
rid of this
b times u partial x and for this we use
this
transformation and this leads us to this
simpler heat equation
and for this example we
we will be showing the trick of this
transformation so this equation
is this problem is solved by using this
transformation and
once the solution is found the the plot
looks like this
so now we have two dimensional heat
equation
in input the first piece is the
two-dimensional
heat equation in rectangular coordinates
the second one
is the initial condition and the rest
are the boundary conditions and
for this example we have a mixture of
boundary conditions
like neumann rubin
and dirichlet conditions so the solution
is
again an infinite sum but this time we
have a double summation
and
here the solution is valid uh
provided that this this condition is
satisfied so this condition is
for the eigenvalues so in this summation
we need to
[Music]
compute the eigenvalues satisfying this
condition first and then compute the
summation
so for practical reasons uh first let's
compute the first 100 eigenvalues
satisfying this condition and then
we can compute the summation
if
[Music]
so this is the truncated solution we
truncated the
100 eigenvalue and
the solution will be
looking like this and
so we can see how it changed
through time
okay this time we have a
three-dimensional heat equation
okay the first piece is the
[Music]
three-dimensional heat equation
in rectangular coordinates and again
we have a mixture of boundary conditions
we have
neumann condition ruling condition and
dirichlet condition
again the solution is valid provided
that the eigenvalues satisfy
this condition so
again we need to first compute the
eigenvalues
satisfying this condition and then we
can
compute compute the truncated solution
for practical purposes
so suppose we compute the first
202 eigenvalues this time
and then suppose we
in this we let
the other infinity infinities to be
50
like here so if you computed
compute the truncated solution and if we
plot the counter plot 3d for t equal 5
the plot will look like this and
for the same solution for t equals 15
the plot will look like this
so this covers the rectangular
coordinates for the sheet problem and
now we
we work with polar and cylindrical
coordinates
the first problem is a team circular
plate with circular symmetry
since we have circular symmetry
we have no tether dependence so the
first
piece here is the
heat equation in polar coordinates with
not
theta dependency and we assume that at
r equals 0 solution
is solution is bounded
so we just have one boundary condition
for
r equal one
so if we compute
the solution and then plot it
for setting infinity to hundreds
and the solution will look like this
over here
and if you plot the same solution over
a circular domain for t equal
0.45 then the solution
the plot will look like this
the next problem is this time we have no
circular symmetry so we have theta
dependency
so in this case we have r
theta and t as independent variables
and
solution is valid provided that this
condition is satisfied
so similar to the rectangular case we
first need to
compute the eigenvalues satisfying this
condition
so for practical purposes here we
computed the first 50 eigenvalues and
then
we sum up to 50
and this gives us the truncated solution
and if you complete this
manipulation then we get a
manipulate function
okay the next problem is we have a
cylinder with angular
periodicity so
this time the binary conditions are
periodic so
here we have a boundary condition
relating uh negative pi to
pi and so this
in this case we we look for solutions
with
periodic boundary conditions
and we compute the solution
and again we have a double summation
and we compute to
truncate the solution and if we plot for
t equals five
then the the blood will be looking like
this
and for t equals 15 uh plot will
also look similar
very slight difference
okay this covers the heat
problems and now we are ready to start
with
wave problems uh similar to heat
we will be starting with rectangular
coordinates and
the first one is the one-dimensional
wave equation
but this time we have a general type
equation with restoring terms
this is the restoring term and this is
the
damping term so the solution
is expected is an infinite sum and if we
plot the solution the solution will look
like this
the next example is when we have
inhomogeneous boundary conditions uh we
have
inhomogeneous boundary conditions over
here
and so
these terms come from the inhomogeneous
boundary conditions
and if you compute the truncated
solution
for infinity going to
a thousand and if you plot solution the
plot will
be looking like this
next example is when we have wave
equation in ba
in unbounded regions we have now we are
working
over the half line and the problem is
this
so we we have uh initial condition like
this and
boundary conditions are neumann type
sorry one of the boundary conditions uh
are
rich recognition and the other one is
neumann condition
so the solution
is a piecewise solution given in this
form
and if you plot the solution then we get
a plot
looking like this
so suppose we have vibration problem
and there are forces acting on on
on the system and the conditions are
the binary conditions are given a as in
as as neumann condition
so since we have
uh
okay the solution is
found as this one and if you set
infinity to a hundred and then plot it
the plot will be looking like this over
here
next we have two-dimensional wave
equation
so the first piece over here is the
two-dimensional
wave equation in rectangular coordinates
and then we have the initial condition
and the rest are the boundary conditions
again
and again again we have a mixture of
boundary conditions
and the solution involves a double
summation
and if you plot the
truncated solution and
animate it the solution will be
will be varying over time like this
okay here we have a three dimensional
wave equation
we have a triple summation in the
solution
and for t equal five
if you if you plot the counter plot
3d the solution will be looking like
this
and 40 equals 15
a slight variation in the blood
next we have a symmetric uh vibration of
a circular
membrane so we switch to polar and
cylindrical coordinates
and in this case
since we have symmetry there is no theta
dependency
we just have r and t in the system as
independent variables
and the solution is found as infinite
sum
and when we plot it the solution will be
looking like this here
the next example is the vibrating drum
head
so
the solution again
is an infinite sum and we computed
we computed the truncated solution
and run an animation
and the solution will be varying
over time you
okay
okay
next piece is examples on
laplace problems again
starting with rectangular coordinates we
have a potential
problem in a rectangle and the solution
is an infinite sum and the plot
will be looking like this here
so the next step example is potential
element
along an infinite strip or infinite team
plate so
if you want to study steady state
temperature distribution
in a template this is usually a
type of problem that we deal with and
the solution involves an
[Music]
integral so for practical purposes
uh we switch from integrate to n
integrates for
numerical evaluation and
if you plot the solution the solution
will be looking like this
next laplace problem in 3d
so in this case
uh like similar to the heat and
veil problems we get a solution with
double summation
and then when we plot
a counter plot of this solution the
solution will look like
this
and now uh we have a laplace equation in
a template
in in in polar coordinates
uh so
here the solution is found in in terms
of polylog
and when we plot the solution the
solution will
be looking like this here
next example we have a potential and a
team plate
with periodic boundary conditions so we
have here
this t here these are periodic boundary
conditions
and the solution turns out to be fairly
simple
and we can easily plot the solution and
the solution will be
looking like this
the next example is we have a neumann
problem in an analyst
and we have a ps5 solution
and the solution is valid inside the
analyst
and when we plot the solution the
solution will be looking like this here
okay this covers uh our latest
developments in
in classical problems and the next one
uh i want to talk about is uh
what we have done with uniformed unified
transform methods
so this is a method and it has been
widely studied
uh initially
developed by focus and his co-workers
and it has three cases the first case is
the whole line
case and in this case we do not have any
uh restriction on on the
order of the derivative so for instance
in this example we have gone up to
order 12 so
it could be any order provided that it's
it satisfies the conditions of the
method
and the solution is returned
fairly simple and we can easily check
that it's true
next case is half line case suppose we
have schrodinger equation with zero
potential
and we have this initial condition and
this boundary condition
since we we are working on half line we
just have one boundary condition
and the solution is the solution
involves
uh universal integrals and these
integrals are usually very
hard to compute
even even even numerically
and they have also suggested a method
for computing these
integrals numerically
so the last case is the finite interval
case
so
this time again we have a schrodinger
equation with zero potential
and we have dirichlet and rubbing
conditions
so the method determines how
how many binary conditions are required
and
unity provides so many uh
boundary conditions in order to to make
this
method work uh and
again we have a fairly long solution
with integrals okay
so this covers the finite interval case
so we have developed a
vast variety of new and improved methods
for solving pdes
symbolically and we have been testing
our
developments on on collection of
problems and
for instance
for the collection from articles book i
mean we have
uh quite high success rates
like 93 percent uh and for the
next release we are working on a
manuscript
which is describing all these
developments and also other aspects of
pd
pd solving symbolics pde solving in
dissolve let me quickly show
a few pages of it so it starts with a
introduction and
so it talks about
midst of characteristics
and it has
okay so this is still a very
road draft and we are working on it so
hopefully in the next release it will be
complete and it will be available to
the the users so
this is all i have for today and
if you have any questions i will be
happy to answer
and if i missed some of your uh
questions over the chat i i will
i will make sure i get back to you
after the talk